foreign
because this is common misconception I
have a family member who recently was
diagnosed with high LDL and the first
thing the doctor went to is we need to
put you on a Statin in perpetuity right
and when I look at her yes she's up
there in age uh late 60s early 70s but
has the health of an average probably 45
or 50 year old but just sees this one
marker on a test and we now think that
she should be on Statin so can we talk
about is LDL high LDL cholesterol bad
and also are statins problematic in any
way what are statins and what is LDL
right right this is a super important
question I'll do my best to make it
palatable but it's not going to be in 60
seconds so that clock
we don't even need the clock
um so LDL cholesterol is low density
lipoprotein it's a balloon it's a it's a
spherical molecule in your body that has
a single lipid monolayer and it carries
cholesterol and triglycerides it's
essentially like a bus that moves from
your liver the bus station to other
tissues of your body and supplies them
with building blocks so now we've
already seen that the LDL has a
functional positive role in the human
body those building blocks being
cholesterol and triglycerides
cholesterol yes is a valuable nutrient
in your body it's the backbone of your
steroid hormones so all progesterone
estrogen pregnant alone testosterone is
built from a cholesterol backbone is any
steroid backbone it travels on an LDL
bus to tissues of your body now there's
buses that go back and LDL can go back
or HDL buses can usually go back to the
liver this is obviously an
oversimplification there's lots of buses
that move around your body on bus routes
and so the LDL is carrying past
passengers they get off at certain stops
other passengers can get on and move
back to the liver generally speaking now
in in in the LDL particle there are
these other molecules triglycerides and
cholesterol but we think of cholesterol
as misnomer because cholesterol is the
steroid molecule but LDL is a type of
cholesterol but LDL is not cholesterol
in any way shape or form it's just a bus
that carries a cholesterol molecule so
LDL canonically has been thought of as
bad but let's reframe it let's just back
up and think
why would a molecule that is essential
for human life be bad for us
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me
um and we know there are genetic
syndromes where you don't make enough
cholesterol because of an enzymatic
genetic defects in the cholesterol
synthesis pathway the liver makes a lot
of cholesterol you eat cholesterol and
the liver makes cholesterol and the
liver exports it on the bus to other
parts of the body but there's a
condition called Smith lemly opposite
syndrome where one of the enzymes in the
synthesis of cholesterol in the body is
broken and you don't make a lot of
cholesterol these kids have depression
they have sleep issues a lot of them die
in utero and they have massive
susceptibility to infections and they're
given egg yolks as a therapy for their
disease so they're given basically a bag
of cholesterol which is an egg yolk to
treat their disease we know that in
animal models if you deplete an animal a
rat or a mice a mouse of cholesterol of
LDL cholesterol they're more susceptible
to infections if you give a rat or a
mouse more LDL cholesterol they have
more resilience to infectious insults we
know that in humans and this has been
studied at many different levels those
humans with higher levels of LDL tend to
resist infections and have less Hospital
admissions and in the elderly in elderly
cohorts 75 and above I believe those
with the highest levels of LDL live the
longest and have the most longevity so
there's a real conundrum here in Our
Minds when 99 perhaps of doctors would
tell you that LDL is bad how can this be
and I think it's because the LDL
molecule gets associated with increased
levels of heart disease so often in
tests and humans whether these are
observational epidemiology studies and
we say those people in some people as
the level of LDL Rises
in the body we see an increase in
cardiovascular disease cardiovascular
disease being this process of
atherosclerosis right the formation of a
plaque in the arterial wall so
atherosclerosis heart disease is in the
arterial wall you have an artery and if
you cut that artery in this direction
and you're looking down the center of
the pipe the wall of the artery is where
all the action happens for
atherosclerosis atherosclerosis and
there are levels of cells in the
arterial wall there's an endothelium
which is the inside there's an intima
there's a media and so sub intimally
between the intima and the media is
generally where the atherosclerotic
plaque happens and in people who have
higher levels of cholesterol at a very
basic high level you may see an
association between more LDL in the
blood higher levels of heart disease
but if you look deeper it gets really
interesting because in many population
studies uh and Hanes which is a
population or Framingham study if you
break that relationship down and I
almost need a whiteboard to explain this
but you let's look at a relationship on
the x-axis you have the the amount of
LDL cholesterol in the human body and
say it's running from 100 to 150 to 200
milligrams per deciliter and then above
200 and on the y-axis you have incidence
of cardiovascular disease the percentage
of people or the relative risk of
developing a heart attack or the
precursors meaning this atherosclerosis
in the vessel wall
if you look at the Framingham data
overall as you go up it's a it's a
straight line that kind of goes up to
the right meaning the more cholesterol
the more heart disease but if you break
the cohort down by a third variable and
that variable gives you some indication
of your metabolic health or your insulin
sensitivity a very different pattern
emerges and you get four lines based on
the metric that I've seen used as HDL
cholesterol so HDL is canonically
thought of as good cholesterol but it's
much more complicated than that but in
this case HDL is a good proxy for
insulin sensitivity because generally
people who are more insulin resistant
which is synonymous with pre-diabetes
and diabetes have lower HDL diabetics
tend to waste HDL it's just human
physiology that a pre-diabetic or
diabetic State results in higher
triglycerides and lower HDL so if you so
if you sub fractionate the total cohort
of the Framingham study by HDL you get
four lines right HDL less than 25 or 25
or less HDL 25 to 50 HDL 50 to 75 or HDL
above 75 you can choose whatever cutoffs
you want and
and the people with the highest HDL
there's essentially these are people who
are going to have generally insulin
sensitivity they're going to be
metabolically healthy right people with
the lowest HDL most likely to be
diabetic pre-diabetic insulin resistant
okay follow me so far yep
people with the highest HDL in the
Framingham cohort have basically a
straight line that's flat they don't
have any connection between the amount
of LDL in their body and the incidence
of coronary heart disease oh wow the
people with or like a very very small
upslope very small okay people with the
lowest HDL looks like this meaning that
the more higher your LDL the more heart
disease you have and there are multiple
studies that show this in humans who
have high HDL and low triglycerides
which is a clear marker of insulin
sensitivity and metabolic Health there
is very little if any relationship
between the amount of LDL in your blood
and the incidence of cardiovascular
disease but in both instances that LDL
bus is going to be consistently
traveling it's always traveling and so
that's what makes us say it's correlated
with that the LDL is always there yeah
but what we see is that when you if you
if you stratify Studies by insulin
sensitivity we know that the single
greatest risk factor I would argue for
determining whether your LDL is going to
be connected with heart disease is your
insulin sensitivity but most most people
don't understand that so when you're
when your family member had her
cholesterol checked I'm willing to bet a
very nice delicious ribeye steak that
they did not check a fasting insulin
they they probably did zero metrics to
look at her fasting insulin or her
metabolic health so we know very clearly
in medicine that your metabolic health
is the context by which we should
evaluate the risk of your LDL load but
doctors don't do that so we're Flying
Blind we're only using half the
variables that we should be using
there's no contextualizing because
Western medicine isn't good at
contextual Nuance at all we just want to
say you have high LDL we know that in a
population if we give you a Statin and
I'll talk about statins in a moment we
will slightly reduce your risk
especially if you've had a heart attack
if you haven't had a heart attack
there's not a lot of great data for
statins and primary prevention
but so their Western medicine is not
good at individualizing care for humans
they're they're okay at looking at a
population swath but for anyone who's
listening to this podcast or thinking
about these things with Nuance or making
intentional decisions with regard to
their food and lifestyle Western
medicine is not really going to serve
you with the level of like Clarity and
like specificity that you really need
and so they're not even going to check
what her insulin sensitivity is they're
not going to say you're metabolically
healthy and if we look at the data
someone who's metabolically healthy with
your level of LDL actually doesn't have
an increased risk of heart disease so
why would we give you a Statin which we
know interrupts the synthesis of
cholesterol and the human body and has
tons of side effects because when we're
interrupting the synthesis of
cholesterol we're also interrupting the
synthesis of coenzyme Q10 which is a key
part of an electron transport chain
which is how all the energy in the body
gets processed and translated into
useful currencies ATP and things like
that so many people who take statins get
muscle aches because they because
because they're we've we've abrogated
we've basically stopped their production
of critical nutrients that are in the
same pathway as cholesterol and so
Western medicine says oh it's okay we'll
just give you more coenzyme Q10 well
what about the squalene or these other
you know nutrients that the human body
is making in the cholesterol pathway
we're not supplementing all of those and
how bioavailable is this coenzyme Q10
that they're giving you and if a doctor
gives you coins on Q10 when you have
muscle aches on a Statin that's a very
astute position in the first place most
of them will just say stay on the Statin
the most important thing is that I don't
get sued for you getting a heart attack
with this LDL so
it's a very complex situation but let's
just back up again and really kind of
summarize what we're dealing with here
here's the question that I would ask
because there are a lot of really
well-intentioned super smart people in
the space who believe that something
called APO B which is a lipoprotein that
identifies that sits on LDL another bus
called vldl another bus called
chylomicrons so they say APO B
containing particles are atherogenic
they create atherosclerosis that doesn't
make sense to me that a particle that
exists in the human body that carries
this apoprotein would inherently be
damaging to the endothelium the inside
of our blood vessels and initiate
atherosclerosis
and so the question I always ask these
people is if LDL if APO B containing the
proteins like LDL are atherosclerotic
meaning they have the ability to
generate atherosclerosis on their own by
damaging the inside of the blood vessel
then why don't we get atherosclerosis in
veins and why is it only in arteries so
when you're when when the blood goes out
of your heart
into your tissues that's in arteries
when it returns from your tissues to
your heart that's in veins you can see
veins on the surface of my skin they're
blue you can't see the arteries they're
deeper a lot of track marks there
so the veins are coming back right we
never see atherosclerosis in veins in
humans only arteries and why is that
because the same amount of LDL
cholesterol is circulating in my veins
as in my arteries it's contiguous system
there are capillaries here the blood
gets pumped out of my heart to my brain
and arteries to my legs and arteries all
over my body it's an arteries and then
it goes to capillaries and it switches
and it comes back around makes a U-turn
and comes back to my heart that's how it
works so veins don't develop don't
develop atherosclerosis only arteries
why is that
if able B is initiating atherosclerosis
doesn't make any sense to me and the
answer is that in arteries you have
higher pressure
you know average blood pressure is 120
over 80 millimeters of mercury because
arteries are more muscular they have a
an outer layer a muscularis layer that
is much bigger than a vein but the inner
part the endothelium is exactly the same
so arteries are much more muscular
because they must carry more pressure to
push the blood which means that when
there's more pressure there's more
denuding of the endothelium which means
there's more damage just by being an
artery because the pressure in there is
higher so my argument is apob
containing particles like LDL are not
atherosclerotic you need endothelial
damage to initiate atherosclerosis and
then if able B particles get wrapped
into that perhaps as part of the repair
process it could make it look like
they're make it look like they're guilty
right are they the firemen or are they
the arsonist maybe they're arriving to
the scene of the damage in the artery
that is happening because of high
pressure as part of the healing process
and there's more of them in people who
have more susceptibility to damage in
their arteries like diabetics we know
that people who are insulin resistant or
back to that term insulin resistant they
have more they have impaired wound
healing we hear about this all the time
in diabetics you get a amputated toe or
a leg or a foot yeah they have very
impaired wound healing and we know that
in the artery
at the level of the endothelium just by
living a diabetic is damaging their
endothelium just like you and I are
damaging the endothelium of Our arteries
by having pressure but neither you or I
are diabetic neither you or I are
insulin resistant so our body has the
ability to repair those things properly
to go in with immune cells and repair
the endothelium but a diabetic someone
that's insulin resistant is going to
have impaired wound healing and that
leaves more holes in the facade where
there is damage where the LDL particles
are being called and there's an immune
impairment in the process of repair and
that is what causes atherosclerosis does
that make sense that makes sense if
someone is metabolically damaged and
they have decreased insulin sensitivity
is that repairable it's absolutely
reversible by changing the diet and so
just to summarize here with respect to
LDL cholesterol Dr Paul saladino is not
that worried about LDL cholesterol some
doctors are worried because they're
afraid of being sued and so then they
recommend statins which might be
worrisome for many people but because of
the side effects and speaking of not
being sued I should remark that nothing
on this podcast is medical advice
and so please consult your doctor your
astrologist your pet care facilities and
uh your yoga instructor before
implementing anything into your life
don't take responsibility for yourself
please Outsource it to everyone in your
community because you're not responsible
everyone else is responsible for your
health oh my goodness the one thing I'll
just add to your summary is I don't
worry about LDL if someone is insulin
sensitive
in a diabetic do I worry about LDL yeah
but fix the insulin sensitivity right
I'm not the the LDL I think there's
there's a lot of good evidence that we
really need to have these these
discussions among Physicians and and
question the Dogma with regard to LDL I
think just knee-jerk responses saying
your LDL is high you need a Statin is is
not the whole picture you have to
understand the context of that and then
we need to equip Physicians with
education that tells them this is how
you help your patients reverse their
insulin resistance and we need to do
research that actually creates some
substance behind that recommendation so
real quick because someone who goes to
their doctor and their doctor says hey
you have high LDL
and they Panic right away right and
they're like oh they want me to get on a
drug and I can't possibly repeat
everything that Dr saladino just said
and so I just throw up my hands what is
one or two sentences they can say to
their doctor to say I'm not that
concerned about my high LDL because I'm
not diabetic did you check a fasting
insulin can we can we evaluate my
metabolic health
you just say can we evaluate my
metabolic Health the doctor will not
know how to evaluate the metabolic
health so you may need to ask them to
check a fasting insulin and the the last
piece I'll add to this is that
it's very clear in human physiology that
in many humans eating more saturated fat
and less polyunsaturated fat raises the
LDL slightly right slightly ten percent
twenty percent which is why a lot of
people eating in this way will go to
their doctor and have a quote high LDL
the last time I checked my LDL it was
130 milligrams per deciliter which is
just above the normal range saying 120
but most doctors would say you have a
high LDL you should eat less red meat
well yes eating less red meat will lower
my LDL and I could even lower my LDL
more by eating canola oil but what do we
know and what are the doctors missing
something I've hinted at a couple times
in the podcast that if you go a level
deeper
and you look at the predictors of
cardiovascular disease in general LDL is
pretty poor like we talked about what's
a really good predictor oxidized LDL so
you're taking the phospholipids on the
outside of the LDL molecule and asking
how many of them have been oxidized and
we know that oxidized LDL goes up when
you eat polyunsaturated fats even though
your total LDL goes down because you're
populating more of the outside of that
LDL molecule with fragile fats these
polyunsaturated fatty acids so Ox LDL
goes up LP little a which is another
metric of LDL oxidation because it's a
particle that kind of scavenges oxidized
phospholipids goes up when you eat
polyunsaturated fatty acids but your LDL
goes down so most Physicians are just
looking surface at LDL but really we
should be looking at oxidized LDL NLP
little a
and remember that just because eating
saturated fat makes your LDL go up your
oxidized LDL and your LP Little Egg go
down it probably has to do with
something this word is technical so I
apologize in advance called the home
viscous model of membrane fluidity and
the the high level is that when you eat
more saturated fats we know that the
fats we eat become a part of our cell
membranes and cells are very delicate
and very specific about how they want to
maintain membrane fluidity and because
you're eating more saturated fats cells
are probably going to raise the
cholesterol in your bed in your blood to
keep the membrane fluidity at a at a
baseline level so more saturated fats in
the body will in the diet will create uh
increase in blood cholesterol because
your body's trying to maintain fluidity
of the cell membrane more
polyunsaturated fats will probably lower
the blood cholesterol because your body
is trying to maintain fluid of the
membrane but again it's not it's it's
not a bad thing it's not pathological
that when you're eating more saturated
fat the LDL is going up it's your body
just trying to keep homeostasis yeah
that makes a lot of sense yeah
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free